I would say down time with the people I  love you know just sort of hanging time  with my homies I haven't upset sometimes  I feel like I have too much desire you  know like to see and do and experience  everything because no one can do be  everywhere and do everything in a  lifetime but it inspires me it propels  me so I think it's okay something I'm  endlessly curious about is how people  become who they are how people develop  into the human beings that they are  I have zero interest in ecology today  anyway check in with me in about 40  years I think the most important advice  that I've ever gotten is to really be  myself I can't really Excel being  anybody else but if I can be myself at  least I'm being honest and I have the  best shot being who I want to be if I  can be myself